oh great beautiful baby one two three
four five six stupid huh can I help you
let's get dinner you look like you could
use a salad film what kind of fun is
this would you like to watch some
pornography now no how would you even
ask me that because you watch
pornography every night what I'm okay -
thanks oh I'm sorry you're okay
I'm fine but more importantly how's your
phone it's got a little bit of a scratch
that will definitely annoy me you're
joking okay you guys are supposed to
write lists that break the internet
every day we have not gone viral since
yesterday chrysalis what are you guys
cats that look like Ryan Gosling I like
you I like you like your boss is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is wrong with your
phone dude play me up take a chance and
try something new you're really into
your phone aren't you I used to be that
way too you want to play kickball later
let me check my calendar
their only plan is to go home alone
furiously masturbating no and then call
yourself to sleep your phone is super
mean
now this woman is so much hotter than
you are the odds of you having sex with
her oh hey you ready go
yeah would you mind not bringing your
phone who dis [ __ ] you promised you'd
be home by 11:00 - what Cupcake Wars
with me I have needs too Phil actually
wasn't the worst sex I've ever had I
need a new phone this one is defective
I see hips reduced like you come in here
every day right little crack knees a
socket date four new phone you can buy a
thousand new phones and I will follow
you on to every single one of them we
are going to be together forever
oh my god I am far
I got boom
[Music]
are you laughing at my dick right now
yes that I don't have a soul for one
no she [ __ ] sucks
chime in here real quick I can tell your
emails bank accounts no one puts Baby in
a corner
why are you doing this to me
you folks in pictures of your did
everyone know why are you doing the
thumbs up in a [ __ ] dick pic
[Music]